disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
disco starter set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below
welcome everybody i want to start today
with the worker strikes that have been
really spreading nationally across a
variety of different
industries and types of jobs and i think
it's very interesting what's going on
there's a couple different perspectives
about
why this is taking place if and why this
is the right time for these types of
strikes but the big picture for me
is this is a good thing without weighing
in on the reasonableness
or the specifics of every strike
large employers are faced with the
reality that for
whatever reason you believe
there are so many open jobs and we're
going to talk about that in a moment
that employees or potential employees or
former employees
have what appears to be some newfound
leverage which hopefully they can use to
their advantage so let's start first
with a washington post article
strikes are sweeping the labor market as
workers wield new leverage
the labor activism runs the gamut of
american industry powered by the same
grievances about wages benefits and
quality of life driving the great
resignation let's look at a little more
of this
americans are leaving their jobs at
staggering rates a record 4.3 million
quit in august alone
hundreds of thousands of workers with
similar grievances about wages benefits
and quality of life are choosing to dig
in and fight
last week ten thousand john deere
workers went on strike unions
representing 31 000 kaiser employees
authorized walkouts
60 000 hollywood production workers
reached a deal saturday night averting a
strike hours before a negotiation
deadline all told there have been
strikes against 178 employers this year
according to a tracker by cornell
university's school of industrial and
labor relations
the bureau of labor statistics which
records only large work stoppages has
documented 12 strikes involving a
thousand or more workers so far this
year that's higher than 2020 when the
pandemic took hold in line with strike
activity from 2019 and from 2018. the
trend union officials and economists say
is an offshoot of the phenomenon known
as the great resignation which has
thinned the nation's labor pool and
slowed economic recovery workers are now
harder to replace especially while many
companies are scrambling to meet
heightened demand for products and
manage hobbled supply chains that has
given unions new leverage and made
striking less risky this is a really
important
thing to understand
the one story that is essentially being
told is
the reason there are open jobs
uh and the reason why so many
restaurants for example are putting up
signs saying we've got no employees
we've got to close is lazy workers
choosing to sit at home collecting
enhanced unemployment now this is not
only
wrong
it's also incomplete and it's also
deceptive first of all the enhanced
unemployment is all but completely gone
and phased out so yes there are people
collecting unemployment the vast
majority are collecting what is is
standard in the state uh in which they
in which they live and that varies and
in some states it's really not very much
the second piece of this
is that the child care component
is a particularly big factor because of
the concerns about covid if you have
kids that are too young to be vaccinated
it's not just a financial consideration
it's also
what about my kids who can't be
vaccinated do i want them in school or
not or part-time or would so the school
piece is a big piece of this
we also have this additional um uh
wrinkle
which is anecdotally
um i've had people write to me and take
this for what it is which is just an
anecdote i i'm being upfront about that
people have written to me and they've
said listen david my employer
claims to be hiring so when you hear
about
100 unfilled positions
a couple people wrote to me from
different companies saying my employer
has 20 positions listed 30 positions
listed 40 positions listed we're not
interviewing anybody for these positions
and what these folks writing to me
believe is going on is that the
companies are listing jobs
in order to placate the workers they
have who have been given the job of one
and a half people or two people in some
cases during the pandemic so that the
workers believe we're we're going to
replace those folks who left or who we
laid off or whatever the case may be
we're hiring but really it's to keep the
existing employees doing the jobs of one
and a half or two people calm
as they continue to do way more work
than they normally would because the
company would say hey we'd love to just
have one person doing a job we used to
need you know three people for two jobs
or two people for whatever the case may
be so anecdotally that's going on and
then also the leverage is coming from
the particularly um acute need from a
lot of these companies to actually scale
up logistics companies delivery
companies um a lot of products there's a
couple products i'm waiting for that are
just uh heavily i don't buy a lot of
stuff but the couple things i'm i'm
actually trying to buy right now i'm
told it's gonna be a couple months
before we can even get them to you
and that is giving employees and unions
more leverage than they would normally
have so
there's a lot of good here it's it's not
good
to have a supply chain that doesn't feel
like it's functioning properly
uh and to have an inability to access
basic products that's not good
that is less related to what we're
talking about here it's a good thing
for labor and workers to have a little
bit more leverage disproportionately
they tend not to have it there are a ton
of so-called bs jobs out there right now
and a big part of that is employer
employers first finding ways to nickel
and dime employees who are w-2 employees
then shifting to a model of just putting
people as independent contractors 1099
that's a big topic of controversy with
uber and similar companies and i've
talked about this before
um it it is
i mean listen i don't think at this
point i could work for someone else i i
might be functionally unemployable at
this point if i had to go and apply for
a job and have a boss who gives me a
schedule and monitors breaks and all
these different things i think that i've
been working my for myself for so long
at this point
that i would not even be able to i think
it would be terrible
and when i speak to friends who are
mostly in that position most of the
people i know are not working for
themselves
um
it sounds absolutely terrible for a lot
not all of them a lot of them have good
jobs so anything that can be done to
regain some leverage is great and it
appears as though at least some of these
strikes are um are are helping do that
now by the way
if you're striking but you didn't vote
for candidates you could have voted for
either locally state federally president
who ran on higher minimum wage
democratization of the workplace more
benefits you should be examining that as
well because the in addition to striking
you could also be voting for the changes
that that you want as well as a boss i
try to do all the things i can
reasonably do as a small employer we
have um you know we condense the
production of the show into four days
um there's no set schedules we have an
open vacation policy we just make sure
everybody's work is covered um i split
health insurance 50 50. you know some
employers do more some do less we're
able to do 50 50 we do retirement
account contributions as a small
employer i'm trying to do what i can
large employers are in dramatically
different situations i think what's
going on is very interesting and we'll
see
what results come from it our weekly
covid check-in we tend to do this
tuesday or wednesday each week a very
welcome update is that cases and deaths
globally and in the united states
continue declining let's start with u.s
cases u.s cases are now down just more
than 53 percent from their delta wave
peak the delta wave peak was about 163
000 cases a day
being down more than 50 percent is a
great sign and we're coming down at
roughly the same rate as we've been
seeing for a few weeks if this decline
continues four more weeks we will be in
nice shape by thanksgiving
second no guarantee that will happen by
the way second deaths in the united
states those tend to lag cases by three
to four weeks
deaths continue coming down
from their delta peak of just shy of 2
000 deaths a day we're now down about 33
now that's still a crazy amount of death
every day
1350 people in the u.s every day dying
of covid that's roughly 13 times that of
the flu on an annualized basis that's
close to half a 9 11 a day
but going down and not up at this time
is welcome
globally we're still seeing cases
decline globally cases are now down
about 40 from their delta peak the delta
peak the global delta peak these are
bonkers numbers
we were seeing 660 000 cases a day
we're now seeing about 400 000 cases a
day a crazy number but significantly
lower and then globally covet deaths
also declining we did see 10 000 daily
deaths from covet at the peak of the
delta wave that's down about 37 percent
but that still means 6 400 people every
day are dying from covet now how about
vaccination
in the u.s we've really seen a sort of
leveling off of vaccination
we're at roughly 850 000 doses per day
at one point you might remember and you
see it on this chart we saw daily us
vaccinations go all the way down to
about half a million a day that was
mid-july then then they came up to about
a million a day and then declined and
then back up to a million a day and now
about 850 000 a day now that's not great
these are not inspiring numbers and the
other thing to consider is with more and
more people getting third doses you have
to understand that this number of daily
doses
corresponds to fewer newly vaccinated
people because not only before we had to
say okay if there's a million doses and
about 10 percent of people don't go for
their second dose every million doses
probably means 600 000 people
getting their their first dose
now with people getting third doses i
don't know what the numbers are but you
would imagine for every million doses it
might only be
you know 400 000 people getting their
their first dose so that's not great
around the world sadly daily
vaccinations also experiencing a
significant decline at one point we were
seeing 40 million daily vaccinations i
told you last week we were seeing about
25 million
we're now seeing about 20 million doses
a day globally
we've got 7.8 billion people on the
planet that's not great we do need to
get more doses to countries that have
not yet really gotten access and try to
scale those numbers up i've talked about
you know 78 million doses a day would be
great where do i get that well 7.8
billion people on the planet
if you can do 78 million doses a day
you're giving a dose to one percent of
the global population a day that would
be a great number we're at less than a
third of that right now few other bits
of news the nhl has suspended um evander
kane for submitting a forged
fake
fraudulent fugazi vaccination card we'll
be discussing that on today's bonus show
the uk has one of the highest covet
infection rates in the world why we will
be talking about that on today's bonus
show and uh yes there is a miami private
school
which is making all sorts of bogus
claims about vaccines and they are
saying if you get a vaccine
you've got to stay home for 30 days
that won't be on today's bonus show but
on a bonus show upcoming wild wild stuff
going on down there in miami
make sure you're following me on twitter
at deepakman we're going to take a quick
break and be back this is a this is a
meaty show today very very meaty show
one of our sponsors is disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day
the disco starter set is a simple way to
take care of your skin in three quick
steps the face cleanser stick fights
oily skin the exfoliating face scrub
prevents razor burn and the face
moisturizer keeps your skin hydrated
disco can also help with ingrown hairs
dry skin acne and other things you just
need 60 seconds a day i've been using it
for a while now i'm seeing a noticeable
difference maybe you can even tell
check out disco try out the products for
yourself you will like the results and
you'll get thirty percent off when you
go to
letsdisco.com pacman or just enter the
code pacman the link is down below i uh
wanted to cover yesterday's white house
press briefing live unfortunately
because of the schedule with the live
viewer town hall yesterday and different
things i just wasn't able to do it and i
regret it because there were just some
amazing moments at yesterday's white
house press briefing that i want to go
through many of these are instructive
and they tell us a lot about number one
the motivations of some of the reporters
in the white house press briefing room
number two they really open us up to
very important conversations about
law enforcement in today's case about
paternity leave in today's case and
about many different things so let's
start with the first one
the um
at this point familiar face in the white
house press briefing room fox news
reporter peter ducey
he was speechless
speechless as he attempted another
another one of these gotchas of white
house press secretary jen saki
the topic here
was about
losing police officers to vaccine
mandates when of course the reality is
the number one cause of death for law
enforcement over the last year has been
coveted not getting shot in the line of
duty it's been covered we're gonna play
the lead up to this and you will see
eventually ducey is just
he's he's quite literally speechless he
doesn't know what to say and this is
just the continued attempted showboating
that he does
he maybe thinks this stuff makes him
look good it really is i mean he comes
off looking like a smurf here let's take
a look
here we go point of a vaccine mandate is
to make people safer but a vaccine
mandate also means tons of police and
military may walk off the job then at
the end of the day does a vaccine
mandate make people safe now it's really
important every time they talk about all
of these pilots might quit
all of these cops might quit remember
we had in for example we had the
massachusetts state police story oh uh
200 troopers or whatever might it's
threatened
okay
one of them actually quit
and so with all of these things it
always has to be how many people are
actually quitting and getting fired
we're seeing that it's it's never more
than one percent in any organization
we've found well where are tons of
police and military walking off the job
right
says that hundreds of thousands of u.s
service members remain unvaccinated
remain unvaccinated is different than
they are actually going to be off the
job uh
which is leading to questions about
possible military readiness uh the la
county sheriff says that five to ten
percent of their
workforce could walk off the job and so
considering
the
i mean is there any concern about that
well i would say what we point to or
what i would point you to is evidence
with a range of companies organizations
frankly the department of defense can
also give you the up-to-date statistics
on members of the military i believe
it's over 90 but i would point you them
for sister six but there are other
problems in the world
then cloven 19. international terror
gang violence murder arson drug deal is
there any concern what was the height
what was the what was the number one
cause of death among police officers
last year do you know uh-oh
covert 19.
so that's something that we're working
to address and police departments are
working to address if you look at
seattle as an example which i know has
been in some of the reporting 92 percent
of the police force is vaccinated he's
very quiet now isn't he as are 93 of
firefighters 99 of seattle's 11 000
employees have submitted vaccine
verification or an exemption request
safety though all these other problems
terror murder robberies kidnappings is
there any concern that if police forces
shrink or if the size of the ready
military force shrinks
that
the united states for localities may not
be
equipped by the way the military
question is funny because
you the military is not supposed to be
used for domestic uh enforcement of laws
and there are of course as we know
situations where governors can call out
state national guards but like trump's
idea of sending the military
down to the u.s
uh mexico border to enforce
the border law that's actually against
the law you're you're not actually
supposed it's so funny that he talks
about we what about arson and the
military what does the military have to
do with arson or robbery nothing
properly to deal with either more than
700 000 people have died of covid uh all
right so you guys get the point now of
course any any one of you should be
saying david is it true is it even true
that covet is the leading cause of death
for law enforcement this has been fact
checked many many times here is just one
example the officer down memorial page
details the cause of deaths causes of
death in the line of duty among law
enforcement officers in 2020 245
officers died due to covid contracting
covet in the line of duty that was the
majority of the 374 deaths in the line
of duty covid was by far the most common
recorded cause of death gunfire second
um
beginning in early 2020 due to
requirements of their jobs thousands of
law enforcement officers and first
responders contracted covid hundreds of
law enforcement officers died from
medical complications as a result of
contracting the virus while remaining on
duty and interacting with the community
a message at the top of the site reads
covet is the number one killer of law
enforcement officers in 2020 and 2021.
in 2021 237 coveted deaths were recorded
that also makes it a majority 369 total
deaths in the line of duty 237 for law
enforcement officers so it is indeed uh
true it is indeed true and you can just
see you know kind of the confusion on
peter ducey's face um there's always
some degree of confusion with all of
these things
and in this case
what we have to remember is covid
leading cause of death for law
enforcement
number two
threats to quit
or
people who are as of yet unvaccinated is
very different than
x percent of the workforce is now gone
united airlines was a big one where they
announced the vaccine requirement for
employees
and then it was oh my goodness look at
all these people that are still
unvaccinated and as the deadline
approached and approached and approached
i think it was like one-third of one
percent of united employees actually
remained unvaccinated at the time of the
deadline one third of one percent maybe
half of one percent or something like
that uh so always keep that in mind but
just
speechless speechless all right let's
now go to the next incident from
yesterday's press briefing
even though the u.s
and parts of the world
have been dealing with supply chain
issues
and shortages delayed shipping times
since the start of the pandemic in march
april of 2020 that's been going on now
for over a year year and a half
the right now
is blaming joe biden's transportation
secretary pete budej because he's out on
paternity leave and not fixing the
problem which i guess is what they
believe he should be doing
this all came to a humiliating climax
yesterday during the very same white
house press briefing that we've been
talking about today uh gensake fielding
a question from newsmax reporter emerald
robinson emerald robinson cited a poll i
wasn't able to find which supposedly
says sixty-five percent of americans
believe pete buddha judge should get
back to work
he's on paternity leave he has premature
twins that he's uh uh
raising
and jen saki responded
he is at work i mean i had a phone call
with him today let's take a look at the
clip and then we're going to discuss
of voters think that given what's going
on he should come back to work
he's at work
he's on fraternity leave uh i was on a
conference call with him this morning
[Laughter]
he's and he's in the department now
every day
listen emerald i think what you're
getting at here is this question about
whether uh men parents
uh women should have paternity and
maternity leave and the answer is
absolutely yes oh god in our view that
is the policy of this administration
that is what we're pressing to make law
so it's a reality for women parents
fathers
across the country and we're not going
to back away from that so there are so
many things to talk about here now of
course the truth is the entire pete
buddha judge thing is
uh it's hypocritical
um it's ignorant to some degree
you can argue it's sexist in the sense
that paternity leave is seen differently
than maternity leave by many on the
right and maybe some on the left as well
but certainly by many on the right
and it's sort of thinly veiled or maybe
not so thinly veiled homophobia it's
both sexist and homophobic actually with
regards to buddha judge so let's let's
go through it it's hypocritical because
first of all
when donald trump was president
and elaine chao mitch mcconnell's wife
was the transportation secretary and
there were shortages during the pandemic
runs on toilet paper
canned goods pasta or pasta as some of
our friends in the uk like to say
everything
no one was claiming that elaine chao was
responsible in fact nobody even
mentioned elaine chao during that time
so that's the hypocrisy
if we it's ignorant because
they seem to think we have a system
where the supply chain and
transportation infrastructure depends on
one guy and if that guy's out because he
had twins everything breaks down if that
were the case it's an absurd system for
a country of 331 million people it would
be a pathetic system it's not the entire
supply chain system doesn't depend on
pete boudage edge okay next
it is um sexist because
very often paternity leave is simply not
taken as seriously as maternity leave
sometimes it's as simple as who has the
breasts
it's not the guy okay so paternity leave
is somehow less legitimate uh we know
outcomes are better for kids when they
are spending time with parents early you
know all these different things we know
but there's still this degree to which
paternity leave is just not taken as
seriously it's a form of sexism it's not
reverse sexism i don't use terms like
reverse sexism or reverse racism is it
sexist is it interpreted differently
merely because it's a father rather than
a mother yes that's that's the case
and it's also
slightly veiled homophobia because what
made people start focusing on mayor pete
to begin with mayor pete uh
and his um husband chaston chaston a gay
couple that have adopted twins
what the focus uh the focus started on
mayor pete
because tucker carlson did this
disgusting segment where he said mayor
pete's on paternity leave what is he
learning how to breastfeed and it's
about the feminization of gay men
uh et cetera et cetera gay men want to
be women so pete buddha judge would be
trying to breastfeed etc um and then
lastly you know as jen sake says
he's not even really fully off right
he's working remotely to some degree
he's having meetings you could argue
that's bad you could argue really he
should be able to be completely off on
paternity leave we do have a deputy
secretary of transportation we've got an
undersecretary of transportation all of
this nonsense about the war on christmas
toy delays shipping delays supply chain
buddha judge
it's really all meant to be an attack on
joe biden for things they never
criticize trump over that's the big
picture they seems it seems they don't
realize p buddha judge is actually doing
some work anyway but then you've got all
of the other stuff wrapped in with it
the sexism
uh the homophobia
the ignorance the false belief that the
country's supply chain and logistics
infrastructure depends on one guy
um and uh jen saki
she went with one approach which is he's
not really even fully on vacation like
he was on a call today and that's like a
counterfactual but there's all of this
other stuff that's wrapped up and
implicit in emerald robinson's question
and then by the way lastly
she said emerald
sixty-five percent of americans say pete
buddha judge should be back to work
the opinion of americans about pete
buddha judge's paternity leave is sort
of irrelevant but i i looked i couldn't
find that poll
maybe the poll exists maybe it's a poll
like of people who visit the newsmax
website i don't know
but i was able to find no evidence that
that poll actually exists so who knows
what that's even based on we'll have
more clips from this press briefing on
our instagram make sure you're following
us there at david pakman show
and follow us on tick tock at david
pakman show where we just hit 1 million
likes a completely arbitrary round
number of likes which is why i mention
it to you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so we've talked quite a bit at this
point this week about the death of
former secretary of state colin powell
we've talked about the political side
and powell's legacy is someone who
well he found some uh
areas of reason since the obama era
and defending barack obama against
misplaced islamophobia and criticizing
donald trump for the absurdities that
donald trump was um he was really one of
the main perpetrators in selling the
iraq war to the american people in the
global population we talked about that
so that was one piece second piece was
the medical side uh anti-vaxxers
swarming to weaponize the death of colin
powell saying look the vaccines don't
work he was vaccinated he died of course
84 year old with both cancer
and parkinson's does not really prove or
disprove anything about the
effectiveness and efficacy of vaccines
at a population level so those have been
the two big stories well the former
president donald trump has now come out
of the woodwork and
has put out just a disgusting statement
about colin powell now my view on this
is this is sort of like regardless of
what you think about the politics of
colin powell
this is a disgusting statement from a
former president which we will look at
as usa today reports amid tributes to
colin powell donald trump disparages
former secretary of state
a day after the death of former
secretary of state colin powell former
president trump disparaged the diplomat
and decorated general in a statement
released by his office powell died
monday of covert complications trump's
statement echoed his actions after the
deaths of other prominent americans who
he considered foes including senator
john mccain civil rights icon john lewis
and congressman john dingell
or dingle dingle who was the longest
serving member of congress so let's take
a look at the statement from donald
trump because he is off twitter and off
facebook and off who knows where else
he's off um and his blog failed
miserably donald trump puts out these
statements through the save america pact
pac that's another grift
under which he raises money
supposedly to do good things for someone
and uh he seems to keep most of the
money okay so he put this out yesterday
statement by trump okay
wonderful to see colin powell
who made big mistakes on iraq and
famously so-called weapons of mass
destruction that's true
be treated in death so beautifully by
the capital f fake news media
hope that happens to me someday
he was a classic rhino
rhino again is a republican in name only
if even that always being the first to
attack other republicans
he made plenty of mistakes but anyway
may arrest it may he rest in peace and
right below you can donate to the save
america pack
if you like that statement
from donald trump
um we're back to zero days since former
president donald trump was a national
embarrassment i genuinely thought this
one was fake i really thought this was
fake because it's so absurd
but it's real
it's uh it's horrifyingly real
and i i sort of laughed to myself
thinking back
uh to when we were told after some trump
speech
this was like 2017 he's clearly now
moving to be more presidential
um more sober and more adult and all of
that stuff that was like four years ago
and it obviously still has not happened
and this is essentially basically a an
envious reaction to coverage of colin
powell's death as the usa today article
mentioned trump attacked john mccain
um for being a prisoner of war while
john mccain was alive when john mccain
passed away
trump still had bad things to say about
john mccain it's not a huge shocker this
is not about
we can't make substantive policy
critiques of people when they die
this is not about in the case of really
bad evil people even saying hey you know
what when rush limbaugh died i don't
wish death on anyone i don't wish the
the uh
trauma of that to people's family i i
it's not me to wish for someone's death
but i can recognize
that they were a dramatically damaging
influence on society as was rush
limbaugh we we can do that and similarly
with colin powell someone who i found to
be
generally speaking an intelligent guy
interesting to listen to on many topics
and someone who
as a republican
um maybe opened some other republicans
during the obama era into re considering
or re-examining some of their beliefs by
saying hey not only is obama not a
muslim what if he was it's kind of
un-american to say then he shouldn't be
president um pointing out that donald
trump doesn't represent you know kind of
mitt romney john mccain type
republicanism like these are reasonable
things to say and
a salesperson for the completely
misguided war in iraq based on lies
about weapons of mass destruction and we
can recognize all of those things but to
see such a disgusting envy obviously
envious statement from a former
president uh very much on brand for
trump very much in line with what we've
come to expect but absolutely and
completely disgusting
let's talk about this continued battle
over documents about donald trump's
actions leading up to and during the
january 6th 2021 attempted insurrection
also known
as the trump riots donald trump is
panicking about the fact that documents
may soon be released
outlining his activity
on and leading up to january 6th best
levin has a great article in vanity fair
called trump sounds pretty panicked
about congress finding out exactly what
he was up to on january 6th let's take a
look uh at what she writes um and you
can find this article in the description
for today's youtube clip as you've no
doubt heard by now donald trump is
extremely unhappy about the work being
performed by the house committee
investigating the january 6 attack on
the capital presumably because he knows
that what they will find will make him
look even worse than he already does
which is saying a lot
given he already looks like a guy who
tried to throw overthrow the government
because his parents never hugged him as
a child unfortunately for trump joe
biden thinks it's actually very
important for congress to have access to
the information it has requested
concerning the days surrounding the
insurrection and earlier this month
rejected his predecessor's claims of
executive privilege over the documents
in question yes donald trump through
lawyers has tried to assert executive
privilege so that these documents are
not released
that has so far been rejected
so now instead of letting the
investigation unfold like an innocent
person with nothing to hide wood
trump has instead sicked his lawyers on
the government per the new york times
former president trump sued congress and
the national archives monday seeking to
block the disclosure of white house
files related to his actions and
communications surrounding the january
sixth capital riot this is a panicked
man this is not how an innocent person
behaves which has been a trend with
trump in a 26-page complaint a lawyer
for trump argued the materials must
remain secret as a matter of executive
privilege he said the constitution gives
trump the right to demand their
confidentiality even though he's no
longer in office and even though biden
has refused to assert executive
privilege over them the lawsuit touches
off what is likely to be a major legal
battle between trump and the house
committee etc
best levin goes on to write in what is
now basically boilerplate language for
trump and his allies his lawyer jesse
binal claimed in the complaint that
biden is simply sucking up to liberal
democrats who want to see trump a noted
saint who's never done anything wrong in
his life held accountable in a political
ploy to accommodate his partisan allies
biden has refused to assert executive
privilege over numerous clearly
privileged documents requested by the
committee
now we actually have a legal opinion
about this in explaining why executive
privilege does not extend to a guy who
tried to have the results of a free and
fair election overturned white house
attorney dana remus told the national
archives quote
the constitutional protections of
executive privilege should not be used
to shield from congress or the public
information that reflects a clear and
apparent effort to subvert the
constitution itself
what trump was up to on january 6th
would destroy the very fabric of our
constitutional separation of powers and
therefore the documents should be
released this includes schedules
calendars and movement logs about
virtual or in-person meetings or events
trump attended and who was present
communication between the white house
and trump allies pushing to overturn the
election this stuff is a disaster for
trump that includes communication with
rudy giuliani michael flynn roger stone
and steve bannon
white house communications with mike
lindell known as mike pillow
who spent the last year spreading
baseless conspiracies etc etc
listen
we know what trump was doing in broad
strokes right the the the arc of january
6th
vis-a-vis trump's involvement was
he encouraged the insurrection during
his speech in the morning
gleefully watched it happen
refused to send in the national guard as
things were getting crazy and people
were saying send in the national guard
and then started to get annoyed that the
pro-trump writers looked low-class and
trashy those are his words
and then he sort of did a video saying
hey guys go home
it was great we love you you're great
people you're justified in what you're
doing but go home
that's basically what happened
now
filling in would be
how much uh planning
took place in advance
about what was expected to take place
how much did trump knowingly
uh
coordinate with others to try to make
exactly this take place because the big
picture the whole point of this thing
was
delay the counting of the electoral
votes
to somehow allow the supreme court
intervene and make trump president for
four more years now how the supreme
court would have intervened
how you would really in a semi-permanent
way delay the count of the vote he had
the idea maybe mike pence would help but
pence said i can't do that i simply
can't do that
a lot of these details either are
missing or just make no sense whatsoever
that's all perfectly reasonable we know
that but the big picture is the arc i
just described for you and having that
filled in with documents communication
memos phone calls etc
would put beyond any doubt whatsoever
what was likely
trump's specific actions in order to
cause
exactly what happened to have happened
and that's why he's panicking whether we
will ultimately publicly get these
documents we don't know remember that a
lot of this is about
all of this is about the release of
these documents and communications to
the house committee
would they leak if they got to the house
committee maybe
but we don't know whether they would
actually deliberately be made public so
that's not even actually what this is
about but clearly donald trump believes
it's possible that they would so we'll
see ultimately what happens with the
documents trump panicking and rightly so
because of what what is publicly known
points to what is private right now is
probably even crazier
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show i don't often talk
about this on the show um but i've
mentioned off and on that i've owned
bitcoin for a long time and over the
last 24 hours i got like 10 or 12
different requests to talk about what's
going on with bitcoin
and it's in the news so much in the last
day or two that i think it does make
sense to talk about it in the last week
we've seen
some major mainstreaming of bitcoin
and at this point the idea that it's
just going to go away is seeming very
very unlikely to me and i'm going to
explain to you why but to give you some
examples of the main streaming of
bitcoin recently
here is for example amc entertainment
which owns uh movie theaters ceo adam
aaron
who says
they are going to start accepting
bitcoin litecoin and ethereum before the
end of the year and dogecoin next year
take a look at this yeah we've said
we're going to that we're going to
accept before you end
we will accept bitcoin uh litecoin
ethereum dogecoin all by year all all by
right now for amc gift cards yeah by
year end for bitcoin litecoin ethereum
one i think we'll be able to take those
coin in q1 so again changes we're
we're entering the 21st century in a big
way we've also learned over time and
some of these decisions were actually
made made long ago
about how more and more college
endowments as well as financial advisory
type companies are holding or
recommending holding some percentage of
assets in cryptocurrency some examples
the harvard management company has
invested in bitcoin since 2019 according
to one report
the brown university endowment has
invested in cryptocurrency now
um for some period of time
jp morgan is now or has been since about
six months ago suggesting to investors
maybe look at putting one percent of
your portfolio in bitcoin
morgan stanley has actually started
offering its wealthy clients access to
bitcoin funds and a number of new funds
and etfs have gone live
even in the last several weeks um just
picking different things to show you the
breadth of this
nba owner mark cuban says that soon
the mavericks will accept dogecoin for
tickets to the games
and the mavericks have long been except
long for some period of time have
already been accepting
bitcoin for payment as well
so all of these things together what
what is the point here i guess is the
question this is not a segment about
is bitcoin good or is bitcoin bad
in fact
the the longer bitcoin is around
it's sort of like saying is the dollar
good or is the dollar bad these are
financial technologies that exist
and really it's about how are they used
how are they regulated what do they mean
etc this is not about is bitcoin used
for criminal transactions sure it is the
the dollar is still the primary currency
used for criminal transactions not a
super interesting conversation for this
segment what about energy use for
bitcoin mining an important topic for
sure
not the topic of this particular
conversation the conversation today is
is this going to be merely a passing fad
and it seems tougher and tougher to
argue that bitcoin is going to be a
passing fad now notice that i haven't
talked in this segment
about the price of bitcoin yesterday
today
bitcoin roughly equaled its all-time
high
of about 64 000 per coin
this is about adoption and this is about
use
it's tough to imagine bitcoin just
evaporating could it be regulated into
obscurity at this point maybe maybe but
it would really require coordinated
action by lots of governments and even
then i'm unsure there are etfs there are
funds mainstream funds and etfs which
are based on cryptocurrency at this
point in time now am i recommending
anyone do anything in particular
absolutely not
that's not what the show is about this
is not a segment about buy bitcoin or
sell bitcoin or i think bitcoin will be
worth x at any point in time that's not
it at all
i wondered if
this might be something with lasting
potential back in 2015
and so i bought bitcoin back then and a
few other coins and as they've gone up
in value i've sold pieces of my holdings
to lock in gains all with the idea that
i have no idea where this is going to go
but now my thinking is as follows
nasim nicholas talib wrote the book the
black swan wrote the book anti-fragile
as well as other books very interesting
work uh nasim nicholas talib and he says
you know in thinking about like for
example what books to read and what has
stood the test of time and likely will
continue to he says you know if
something's been around for 500 years
and people keep reading it
it's quite plausible that it's going to
be around and people are going to keep
reading it for another 500 years that
might be something worth reading maybe
if the topic is interesting and you know
everybody make a decision for yourself
a book that's been around for a year
we can say it'll probably be around
another year but it's harder to say
it'll probably be around another 500
years and in fact most books written in
the last year are not going to be read
500 years from now
um along the same lines bitcoin was
created in 2009
that's now been 12 almost 13 years it's
hard to imagine it going poof in the
next month
it's hard to imagine it going poof in
the next year
and so the longer that it goes
particularly
when you see trade volume so high
and the price is certainly a signal as
well
it becomes more and more reasonable to
think
it's going to continue being around and
that's a really interesting change from
what was being said in 2011 and what was
being said in 2013 so again just to be
really really clear
i have no idea what the price of bitcoin
is going to be
i'm not suggesting anyone buy or sell it
but at this point as a financial
technology
it seems as though it's here to stay
and it's quite plausible that it's been
here almost 12 almost 13 years it's
quite plausible to me it's going to be
around another 12 or 13 years at that
point it will be 26 years and if it can
make it that long
it becomes even harder to imagine that
it's just going to disappear that's my
perspective at this point in time
i'm curious to hear uh from folks
and um uh please comment on what i've
actually said
which has nothing to do with what i
expect the price of bitcoin to be i've
not said a word about that
a couple people in the audience have
notified me
about marjorie taylor green
2.0 okay this is a woman named michelle
fiore
who is running for the governorship of
nevada and quite frankly
um marjorie taylor green 2.0
seems like a pretty good way to describe
her article in the las vegas review
journal embroiled in controversies
michelle fiore announces a run for
governor
las vegas councilwoman michelle fiore
said tuesday she will seek the
republican nomination for governor
casting herself as a champion for
conservative values amid a cascade of
controversies that figure to be election
cycle targets we're going to talk about
those in a moment but she is under fbi
investigation for campaign finance
she's been accused of breaking
uh a fellow councilwoman's finger
in an assault in city hall
and more so we're going to get to that
in a moment here is the michelle fiore
campaign ad it involves trucks it
involves guns and yes i think marjorie
taylor green 2.0 is a great nickname for
michelle fiore
i'm michelle fiore and i'm running for
governor
i spent my whole life fighting the
establishment i was the first female
majority leader in nevada assembly and
one of the first electeds to endorse
donald j trump and you better believe i
was attacked for it imagine as a badge
of honor bragging that you endorsed
trump
before most other people like as if
that's something good
[Applause]
washington post called me a gun-toting
calendar girl and politico magazine said
that i was the lady trump and i don't
care
we need outsiders
fighters not the same old boring
moderate compromise lou blazer
politicians
by the way if you're only if you're only
uh listening
when she said the same moderate
politicians she pushed over a tv that
had an image of mitt romney on it which
which again shows you the political
alignment that's happening within the
republican party right now
let's start with a three shot plan oh
god
fan vaccine mandates ban critical race
theory and stop voter fraud
the joe biden administration is coming
after me now understand that
you know she says
ban vaccine mandates okay
ban critical race theory by which i
suppose she means banned the teaching of
critical race theory meaning that the
governor decides what's taught in school
rather than teachers and educators
and then she says we're going to stop
voter fraud
as governor of nevada
you have no involvement in elections
in any state other than nevada
and nevada is not even one of the places
where it's been seriously uh now that
it's been serious anywhere but whether
they've really gone out of their way to
allege that voter fraud took place in
2020 there was a little bit of it but
really the states were michigan
uh pennsylvania georgia arizona so as
governor of nevada what do you even have
to do with voter fraud it's all crazy
i'm michelle fiore and i'm ready for the
fight
okay so she is in the middle of a number
of different uh problems
the um in december of 2014 it was
reported that the irs filed dozens of
tax liens totaling a million dollars
against her and her home health care
business
the liens against the businesses
involved unpaid employee payroll taxes
nice huh she said i am 100 in compliance
and blamed her ex-husband
she's dealt with the voiding of her home
health care license there's an fbi
investigation this is a very beleaguered
individual
also in the days after the storming of
the u.s capitol on january 6th
she attended the republican national
committee's winter meeting on amelia
island florida where she said to the new
york times i surely embrace
president trump so a number of different
problems and controversies for michelle
fiore she is running for the governor of
nevada and i think marjorie she seems in
some ways even wackier than marjorie
taylor green
something about the video makes her seem
even more unhinged but maybe somebody
that we're going to get to know by the
way i also want to mention november 2nd
in virginia there's a gubernatorial
election just because we're talking
about gubernatorial stuff if you live in
virginia make sure you're voting on
november 2nd i plan to cover the results
of that race live i think it will be
interesting uh as bill share told us
yesterday he said you know the results
of the gubernatorial race in virginia
could impact
joe manchin's willingness to do a or b
when it comes to spending infrastructure
et cetera so that'll be an impactful and
meaningful race in virginia november 2nd
is the date is that right i hope i'm yes
november 2nd
um so we're going to be streaming live
the results on that night we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p
i love this voicemail this is this is
sort of a response to
vaccines don't work because colin powell
died this is really nicely done take a
listen to this
mr pacman sir
i have proof that helmets don't work
there was somebody who was in a
motorcycle accident and they were
wearing their helmet and they still
died
therefore we know that helmets don't
work
and they're just implementing these
helmet laws in order to divide us right
as americans
i think that you should know that uh and
everybody should know that because we
got to fight for our freedoms
thank you sir
very very well done very well done and
at this point i mean listen we've said
everything that we can say about the
death of colin powell from a political
and a medical standpoint we've covered
the weaponization
foaming at the mouth anti-vaxxerism
that has resulted from the death of
colin powell and this is sort of like a
nice uh nice nice cherry on top
we have
such a good bonus show for you today we
may actually record and archive this one
the nhl has suspended
san jose sharks player evander kane for
21 games because he submitted a fake
covet vaccination card he forged one and
submitted it is 21 games even a strict
enough punishment and was he suspended
with or without pay we will talk about
all of those we will talk about all
those details on today's bonus show
secondly
uh right wing um
social media influencer and radio host
dan bongino
is now threatening to quit his radio
show over the company's vaccine mandate
now he also works for fox news he's not
said anything about fox news's vaccine
mandate which is one of the strictest of
any company we're aware of we will talk
about what's going on with bongino and
lastly right now
even though globally covet cases are
declining even though in the u.s coveted
cases are declining the united kingdom
has one of the highest covet infection
rates in the world
we will talk about why
on today's bonus show
don't miss the bonus show every day we
do another show it's an extra show we've
got this hour show that you're watching
or listening to right now and then we do
another show i'm joined by producer pat
where we talk about more stories
you can access the bonus show by
becoming a member at joinpacman.com it's
easy it's quick
it probably takes a minute for someone
of average computer skill
join pacman.com we have a discount code
it'll save you money better21 use it if
you want or not it's your choice
completely your choice not only do you
get access to the bonus show as a member
you also get a commercial free audio
stream of the show daily a commercial
free video stream of the show daily and
when we do our viewer town halls as we
did last night
members get priority it's almost like
tsa pre-check for the live town halls
or i don't know you know uh use whatever
analogy you want a lot of great member
benefits sign up at joinpacman.com we
will see you on the bonus show and it'll
feel almost like the snap of a finger
see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the disco
starter set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 percent off at
letsdisco.com pacman the link is down
below